I'm in high school with you okay we're
in tenth grade yep boost on vinyl ah if
it weren't for social media I would be
convinced that someone from high school
right now is thinking of me as a failed
stand-up comic somewhere it was just
like a whole mess Oh alcohol made me
feel like I was suppressing the urge to
dance on the table so you're not a fan
of the universal basic income of $1,000
a month to any American no matter what
I'm super broke living in an apartment
with no furniture I could not see a path
to success wish I had a chance to meet
you away she believed in me at times
when I was like over I don't know if I
can do this that's powerful wait a
minute who doesn't have a bar
everybody's got a bar everyone told us
we were crazy
leaving technology and going into food
let me say that is absolutely nuts what
you guys did one I just want to
acknowledge that you've done your
homework you got a good story
it got so heated I was like we're
actually about to throw punches you guys
are corny crazy okay bowl of it like
what skill set has the highest upset
highest return the little better you
think you can get is the tip of an
iceberg you can radically transform your
life all of us two buttons man this is
crazy and everyone turns I mean they're
like what Dad wax on wax off this phone
crazy ass story
[Music]
what are the things I like about my
guest today he's a trifecta which is
somebody who has his own theories right
they have experience working with other
successful people but they've also
applied their own philosophies to win
because not only has he been successful
as somebody who worked as they may be
the third person in a company then he
want to became a founder with the
company they sold the four billion
dollars he's made a lot of money for
himself you can go search his network to
see what kind of money this is a lot of
people can say their network but this is
like I sold the company for this much
and this is how much money I made so
we're gonna talk about how he worked
with his other two partners and then on
top of that he starts a YouTube channel
called impact Theory which by the way if
you're on social media if you consume
any content on social media you have
absolutely seen this man he asks the
right question great interviewer and he
interviewed me a few weeks ago I said we
got to bring you example into his house
I was blown away by his operation his
organization his ability put it together
so I said we got to bring you here to
Dallas and do the interview
so today's guest is Tom balloon Tom
what's up man thanks for coming out man
thanks for having me yes you're a pro I
like your stuff man you're you're very
different than a lot of guys online I
got to tell you thank you so before we
get into it obviously anybody who knows
you'd have heard your story and we're
gonna go through that part you know
growing a business 57,000 percent first
30 years 1,200 employees I think at one
point you guys had your product quest
bar being sold at what 40,000 different
points that you guys sound like some
stores all these other things and very
very good story so I want to go to that
part and we'll talk a little bit of
family a little bit of current times
what you're thinking about what's taking
place and we'll go from there so before
we do go into deeper into the business
I'm in high school with you okay we're
in 10th grade yep who's Tom vital ah so
I wanted to be a comedian so in 10th
grade that would have been my identity a
thousand percent
oh yes everyday at lunch I practiced my
stand-up so I would let's say we're at a
table with 10 people I would do 45
minute impromptu comedy routine and my
goal always was to get there was one guy
if you could get him just right he'd
actually spit his soda through his nose
so I was always trying to like hit that
level of funny and I just thought that
was gonna be the course of my life in
fact if it weren't for social media I
would be convinced that someone from
high school right now is thinking of me
as a failed stand-up comic somewhere and
before does it start oh is this tenth
grade oh Clark today um it probably so
my sister was really good at sports and
she's older than me so I naturally
followed her into that but I did not
have her proclivity for sports I did not
yet have a growth mindset so I didn't
think I could work to get better so I
stepped into it I had no natural talent
it was very embarrassing some of my most
embarrassing moments are related to
sports I'll give you one quick one I was
the slowest person in the district I ran
cross-country and my thighs used to rub
together till they bled it was just like
a whole mess when you say thighs I mean
were you a heavy yeah I was about 200
pounds when I was 14 so it was all over
you had 14 I was relatively tall but
I'll put me at like 5 8 5 9 I mean
that's your heavy yeah yeah for sure by
today's standards not so much but back
then yes people thought of me as being a
little bit chubby interest but but by
like when people look at my photos from
before it's like you weren't heavy
well that's compared to now so comedian
yeah that was like the whole shtick so
about in seventh grade I found theater I
found that kind of stuff and really
poured myself into speech and debate and
yeah thought I'd be a stand-up comic now
it's a comedian because you had a tough
life growing up because you know
comedians sometimes they have to make
people laugh and have to make things
easier Kevin Hart you know he had to
figure out a way to make himself calmer
in the pressure situation was it just
purely because you like making people
laugh and entertaining people I think
some of it was where do I fit in the
family dynamic
and realizing that oh I I could make
people laugh and then they started
turning to me to make them laugh and
then I found that was a way I think I
would have been picked on a lot if I cuz
I was in band I was a little bit chubby
I was bad at sports so I would have been
picked on but I found that if I could
make people laugh I could disarm them so
the biggest guy in the school once said
yeah don't don't quit Bill you because
he's funny and so like that became my
thing was I could talk my way out of
anything but when I went to college
because my comedy was based on making
fun of myself I wanted to take myself
more seriously I wanted to stop doing
the self deprecation all the time and so
because I didn't have a wounded
childhood because I did not have a need
to make people laugh it was just
something that had served me I stopped
doing it on a dime self-deprecation yep
totally because you don't want that to
be your identity
correct now do you think there's a link
between comedians and genius because
their brain goes a million miles an hour
so if you think they're I think that if
you are good there there is definitely
more than coke out of his nose so you
must be doing something look when you
compare me to a Robin Williams or a
Kevin Hart or somebody like that who's
just at the top of their game
I was never funny like that so I was
what I'll call living room funny so in a
living room situation if I told you hey
I want to be a comedian be like yeah
you're gonna be great this is amazing
but one of the most transformational
moments in my life do you know who Mitch
Hedberg is I don't oh my god Patrick I'm
about to introduce you to somebody here
so I went to I decided I was going to
get back into it so long story short my
life was not going in the direction I
wanted after college I was looking
desperately to find like how am I gonna
get back on track
so I think I'll go back to comedy yet I
was so good at it so I do a routine at
the Laugh Factory
open mic night la la okay and at open
mic night you start with about 300
people and I was the first one there I
did my thing I was funny but not no
one's gonna remember me and everyone
starts leaving as their friend finishes
the open mic and then at the end you get
really famous comedians that come on and
they try new material so it's usually
bad so by the last comedian it's like
I'm not joking maybe 12 people left one
and finally we get to they're about to
announce the last comedian I can't take
it anymore so I tell my friend hey let's
get out of here we stand up this guy
comes onstage he's like yo before you go
you're gonna want to stay for this last
guy because he is the funniest man in
America I thought all right that's
pretty big hype let's see
we sit back down and this guy I've never
heard it before in my life Mitch Hedberg
comes out on stage he is so funny that
part way through the act
I actually think to myself can you die
laughing one time a guy handed me a
picture of me say here's a picture of me
when I was younger every picture is of
you when you were younger because I
can't catch my breath it was insanity
now you can google him he's that funny
and I was like okay I could get that
good but I would have to dedicate my
entire life to it because I now see what
funny is and getting some laughs is
different than making somebody ask can
you die laughing well you know that's
the part that I think you and I have in
common with is did you logically write
their say I don't know if I can compete
with this guy so logically this is not
the business for me I'm leaving this
industry is that kind of what it was I
said it a little bit differently I was
like I needed to believe I could beat
him on a long enough time yeah like I
needed to believe if I put my energy and
I said into this I could beat him and so
I said that to myself but in the room
still they were sitting like sweat from
laughing I was like I'm never doing this
again God because I'm not willing to
give myself over to it that was always
meant to lead me to something else too
so because what I wanted to do was
direct which is like the biggest cliche
of all time so I wanted to direct and I
thought well if I can get attention by
being funny then I've got the
opportunity now you know the other part
that's interesting with me with your
stories the fact that you you're not a
drug guy you said the first time you
tried marijuana you were 26 or something
like yeah well that was the first time I
tried alcohol was even later for
marijuana but yeah so wait a minute
first time you tried alcohol was 26
marijuana is later land said you've
never done cocaine it and nothing else
outside of that so what was is it were
you born in a faith-based family with
strong values and principles no but
there's something about my mom she has a
way of like making it sound like a
really bad idea and my I had a lot of
aunts and uncles and second cousins and
stuff that were all alcoholics drug
addicts and watching them I thought oh
that is not a good look I mean it like
real like some real white trashy stuff
yeah and so I just like no and my mom
was chiming in with it's way bad you
don't want to do it you don't want to
end up like that so she's
my ear making it sound really logical to
not do it and I'm watching people act a
fool who are doing it so I just thought
yeah
was anything she said I was different at
it the ordinary like was it fear-based
apps if you're gonna die you're gonna do
this you'll ruin your life somehow
someway yeah I I when I thought I was
gonna have kids I wanted to ask my mom
like you were so good like neither my
sister or I ever got into trouble
we never did drugs we never drank really
yeah but she wasn't like some tyrants
about it so I had a whole thing where I
was gonna have her document like how
does he did it it's very impressive I
don't know have you ever interviewed
your mom I haven't but I want to do a
legacy video for her I mean it would be
fascinating mortified you're talking
three kids nope no drugs or alcohol to
kids via to kids no drugs no drugs no
alcohol no trouble nothing my sister to
this day is like the most straight and
narrow person you show when you tried it
what was it like for you look yes
alcohol both of them oh alcohol made me
feel like I was suppressing the urge to
dance on the table
it is awesome and I love it the most I
just don't let myself do it because it's
not in it's not congruent with wanting
to live forever there's just too many
downsides but that [ __ ] is fun so like I
get how people get in trouble I just
don't have an addictive personality so
for me it was easy to be like yeah this
is fun but I can weigh it against the
disadvantages and there are way too many
marijuana makes me feel like my head is
heavy and I just want to sleep I do not
understand like there are some people
that metabolize it in a way that they
love it they feel reiative whatever I
feel like someone is pressing play and
pause on my brain it's fun ahsha's so
that didn't work out for you I don't not
at all interest now your friends did
your friends do anything were your
friends drinking were they smoking pot
was in high school but in college yeah
sure okay so in college you around them
they're offering it to you nothing
happens you're saying no not interested
ha so are you processing it because I
understand there's a part where it's mom
told me this but then you leave so did
your parents raise you in a way where
they control you to kind of let you be
so you never have to rebel against them
I never had to rebel against my parents
got it
my dad was into his thing and that like
if anything I was trying to do things to
get my dad's attention but not in a
destructive way but that's part of what
drew me to filmmaking was that was how
he and I bonded
my mom was
tailor-made to be my parent so she did
not play I remember one time my friend
came in to school and he was like dude
my mom tried to slap me and I blocked
her and she burst out crying she's never
gonna slap me again I was like I'm doing
that the next time my mom tries to slap
me on the blocka this is gonna be
amazing and so I'm pushing my mom's
buttons as she goes to slap me to block
it and I'm like this is over I won and
she goes to slap me on the other side
and I blocked that too and I'm like I
shut this woman down and as I'm
celebrating pow she hits me with the
third one and I remember in the moment I
wasn't mad I was like respect like my
mom and not the one that stops and
starts crying when you push against her
like she would just raise the level so
because I had so much respect for my mom
my mom always made me feel crazy loved
like even in those moments and was my
biggest cheerleader and always told me I
could do anything yeah I just never felt
like I had to push back how were her
parents her parents were dysfunctional I
think to say the least and I remember my
mom used to force her parents to hug us
and tell us they loved us because they
never did with her Wow and so she just
wasn't gonna play that with her kids
so for me it was always that it was hugs
and goodnight kisses and I love you and
you know just it was always there but
never trying to control you to the point
where you had to rebuild wow it's weird
like she really did like she instilled
fear but she let that be my own fear
like I was if I was definitely afraid of
failing you got straight A's in my
family that was that but I wasn't afraid
of my parents and then you didn't drink
you didn't do drugs because that was
gonna ruin your life and then I think
because she helped me believe that my
future was gonna be awesome I don't want
that yeah
so now after that you know you go into
wanting to be you know in the film
industry you're wanting to go to that
direction talked a little bit on that
yeah so my dad makes an offhanded
comment when I'm 12 years old so this is
like the classic case of Bill Gates has
a computer when he's a kid and because
of that he's just a little bit ahead of
everybody in that area my dad's work
happened to have a camcorder before
anybody had cameras I mean now like
people today can't imagine a time where
you don't have a camera with you at all
times but when I was a kid I was super
weird and so my dad would bring this
video camera home and me and my friend
would mess around with it and at the
time I thought I wanted
in front of the camera I just always
knew where to put the camera to make
something funny or whatever and so I
slowly started being the guy behind the
camera my dad made an offhanded comment
and he was like I think you're actually
better behind the camera than you are in
front of the camera now he may have been
trying to save me from myself and saying
like you're terrible in front of the
camera kids you should get behind it but
he said it in a way that like made me
think oh wow my dad thinks I'm good
behind the camera so then I started
focusing behind the camera we bonded
over films that was like our stick and I
like I want humans to be blank slates
but the reality is were not and while
our ability to change is astronomical
there are definitely things that we have
responses to and I respond to visual
things with extreme aggression and so
when I see something then it'll hit me
really hard so you didn't have to like
push me to get into film like I loved it
and then realizing that I had an
intuitive understanding of where to put
the camera whatever to make it funny and
then my dad saying that and then like oh
you have to pick something to study in
school it's just like its snowballed and
so it was never like oh this is my
greatest passion it's just like little
by little I became more obsessed with it
more obsessed with it and dove deeper
into it so go to film school and long
story short at the beginning of my film
career is extraordinary I'm killing it
and I thought I was naturally talented I
thought like growth mindset didn't exist
when I was a kid like I never heard
those words until I was probably in my
30s so as a kid it was like you're
either born with it or you're not and so
that's what I thought it was with film I
just thought I I knew how to direct
complete opposite of the way you think
today 1,000% in the opposite direction
and this is what ends up happening is
exactly what led me to that so I'm in
film school my first films are good and
I start getting attention and USC film
schools doggy-dog so statistically
speaking you're more likely to get in
the USC film than you are a Harvard law
so i against all odds they tell me I'm
never gonna get in I lock myself in a
room for two years do nothing but study
so that I can get in as a junior I get
in and now I'm thinking wow I've already
defied the odds my first films are good
start getting attention I get selected
as one of only four people selected to
do a thesis film and they give you a
phantom budget of like 35 K which back
then was insanity
have imagined it and I completely get up
I mean just like so bad I mess up in
every conceivable way you can mess up
and it like broke some part of me how
public of a loss was it massive so first
of all you go from being one of your
entire class to being one of only four
in your class to do the film so all eyes
are already on you to see where you're
gonna do and then people started making
like what we would now call memes but
didn't have that word back then but they
were making like little losers in my
film to make fun of it which was
devastating and then I screened it in
front of family and friends and was just
heartbroken because it was so obviously
bad what role did you know at that
moment where you're sitting in your dorm
room and you're talking to your mom with
the phone hanging down and your friend
comes in and sits right next to you what
does that do say that doesn't happen
does it make any kind of an impact on
your next move you know I've thought
about that a lot and I do wonder
sometimes what my life would have been
if I had had just enough talent to do
well on that film as well and then the
realization comes later in a
professional setting
could that have knocked me off course
it's very possible but what ends up
happening is I have that moment I'm you
know laying in the middle of campus on a
pay phone to my mom saying like I don't
have talent and having this realization
of I'm actually not good and that was
really hard when you think that your
other born with it do you're not so I go
and I graduate and I start teaching and
in teaching I begin to realize two
things one I'm sliding towards
depression and two that I can help these
students make their films better and if
I can help them make their films better
why can't I make my own better how are
you at this guy 22 23 or 22 23 you're
teaching yeah and what school is this
New York Film Academy in Los Angeles in
Los Angeles got it and so this is are
you going at school as well at that time
or you're done with knives done done
with school yeah so was it like
something you wanted to do what you're
just transitional mix move well so I did
a lot of transit transitional jobs and
teaching was definitely one of them but
I was selling video games that sold
insurance door-to-door like I was just
trying to do anything to make ends meet
I'm super broke living in an apartment
with no furniture I mean it's just like
a whole period in my life
and I could not see a path to success it
wasn't like there was that sense of
being lost and hopeless because you
don't know how to break out of it
there was no internet so it's like I
literally have no idea how to get out of
this what year is this this would have
been mm mm yeah 99 2000 was the worst of
it all right before I met my wife who
really helped me turn things how did
that change so one by this point I start
reading about things we would now call
the growth mindset so I'm knee-deep in
Tony Robbins I'm in selling insurance
door-to-door how'd you get introduced it
was it the selling insurance
I was with on the insurance side what
company it was prepaid legal oh really
there's prepaid legal that's a legal
insurance got it so prepay legal was
sold I think a few years ago for 651
it's now a different company name right
now so I think it's called Legal Shield
or something like that so you're selling
prepaid legal is that what introduced
you to a little bit of Tony Robbins it's
possible I actually don't remember but I
started being around people that were
trying to get better and you go to like
sales conferences and they're teaching
how to get better and it's like all
planting this little seed in my mind
about maybe self-improvement is possible
maybe who you are today isn't as
important as who you could become yeah
and so that like ends up being powerful
but like it wasn't like I had some big
epiphany and you're just like huh this
is interesting
then I'm teaching and I'm thinking why I
can make their films better why can't I
make mine better meet my wife and my
wife just takes to that mentality right
from the jump
but then starts pointing out some holes
in my game shall we say to put it
politely
how soon not right at first but when I
went and asked for her father's blessing
to marry her he said no and that that
was eye-opening because he his story is
crazy so he was born in a small village
in Cyprus which is a tiny Greek island
and he clawed his way to the top of one
of the largest shipping companies in the
world I mean just an extraordinary story
and I went to the village that he grew
up in and you think how how did you go
payment no I went with Lisa and my wife
God but not with him but I met his
parents that was surreal that really
brought it doesn't make sense why he is
the way he is no it made it harder to
understand why is that
they were like to give you an idea his
mom he bought her a washing machine and
she was like get this thing out of my
house like she couldn't fathom a
technological advancement like she knew
her ways that was in like she grew up in
the mountains she married someone she'd
known since she was like 5 years old it
was like just like her life was on on
Rails and that was that like what are
you doing with his newfangled stuff and
so they sent him to the mountains to
study and he like really just takes to
it and it's one of those guys that just
had like enough hustler mentality and I
MIDI was always looking for an
opportunity made good on opportunities
nothing was ever below him just like
worked his ass off and what he ends up
achieving is really really extraordinary
and so he's looking at me this broke
undereducated kid and he says how do you
plan to take care of my daughter and I
was like sir I know what you see but I'm
telling you right now I'm the most
ambitious person you've ever met and he
gives me the look that I would give to
somebody that says the same [ __ ] I'd be
like yeah whatever
right like ambition is [ __ ] unless
you have Drive and I didn't have Drive
and so at the same time those words are
coming out of my mouth I'm laying in bed
3 to 4 hours a day every day and the
only thing that gets me out of bed is
the shame of my girlfriend now wife is
working I'm not and she comes home for
lunch and my only responsibility in the
world at that time is to make her a
sandwich before she gets home and so the
fact that like only shame would get me
out of bed in time to do it it was just
crazy it was like teaching about the
semiotic
I was only teaching in the summer so
it's like God really weird cadence like
things are sort of happening at the same
time and it kind of doing sales on the
side yes but that was before I met her
so you not doing sales anymore
not at this point got it so it was yeah
it was a hard time and so realizing that
I have ambition but not drive and that I
need to get some Drive if I'm gonna pull
this off and my wife was very
encouraging but at the same time my wife
didn't pull punches and she's like what
the [ __ ] like you need to do your hair
you need to actually wear nice clothes
because I would just bum around in
sweatpants and wouldn't do my hair and
and I mean look I cannot say enough that
my wife was always loving and
encouraging and always felt like she
shared that vision of who I could become
yeah but it's like it wasn't enough for
her that I was daydreaming about it I
had to be doing something to go get it
and so that that was good like to have
somebody that really held me to a
standard respect to my life so yeah so
that like realizing that and realizing
that I didn't want to be ashamed of
myself anymore I didn't want to be
depressed I wanted to do something
extraordinary but that was gonna demand
a high price and I looked at myself and
just like yeah I'm willing to pay that
price
what what what What did he say when you
said I'll get you a house right next
door to live with us I'm gonna give him
a gun I don't understand why is he
trying to like keep her cool yes let's
see like don't feel married yet hang
tight a thousand ply so one I just want
to acknowledge that you've done your
homework
I'm very good story thank you so yeah so
when I say to my father-in-law hey I
want to marry your daughter he said whoa
whoa whoa don't do that how you gonna
take care of her how about this instead
of you guys get married I'll give you
the house he owned the house next door
to his he said that was always meant to
be my daughter so you guys can have it
move in stay there cuz he know in his
mind he's thinking Oh in 18 months
those guys are done the right keep her
close I don't want her going to America
then it's in because this is all
happening in London I lived in London
for a year so he's like got to keep my
daughter here do not want her going to
America with this loser like can't have
it but if I push back against this kid
she's just gonna go from harder so he's
smart he knows good so he's like hey
take the house he doesn't say you can
sleep with her but that's basically the
read between the lines like being a
relationship be with her live with her I
don't care about that but don't marry
her don't take her to America and so
yeah it was it was awesome and the thing
is he was always very welcoming to me
partly because he's smart and he knows
if he pushes me away then it's all over
and partly because he's a freakishly
kind man so and he ends up becoming an
incredible mentor I mean just like a lot
of amazing things came out of that
relationship but the first one was just
calling [ __ ] on where I was in life
and not letting me hide behind ambition
I had a chance to meet your wife I mean
obviously her energy is unbeliev she can
light up a room when she walks and she's
got that kind of an energy
and you know sometimes this question is
asked but I'm thinking of what you're
what you'll say - this is say you guys
know me it's a you guys don't get
married say that doesn't happen how much
of a role did she play I know you're
talking about
honestly all that stuff a lot of times
you read you'll say you know Michelle
you know they'll say Michelle Obama is
so lucky to have been married to
president and you know that quote she
comes back and says well anybody I would
have married would have become a price
how much do you believe in death yeah I
love that so I'm just a huge believer in
love and partnerships and all of that so
I like that my story is intertwined with
my wife who is an extraordinary human
and I for sure would not be Who I am
today if it wasn't for her now would I
have figured it out other ways because I
don't think you can ever let somebody
own your story I think I'll take credit
for the things that I did my wife could
never make me take action she couldn't
be there for me when I have to push
harder or see something through but did
I have a partner that when I was broken
and on my knees that she got down was
sympathy put an arm around my shoulder
and told me everything was gonna be okay
no I didn't have that what I had was
someone who picked me back up brushed me
off reminded me of where I was going and
who I could become and told me that she
would do anything in her power to help
me become that person ultimately I had
to do the work but like you think you
want sympathy when you're down but what
you want is compassion you want love you
want encouragement you want somebody who
believes in you when you don't believe
in you and she was I have the chills on
my face right now she believed in me at
times when I was like I don't know if I
do
Wow yeah that's powerful and I like how
you said it just to being a cheerleader
is not enough you got to be more than
just a cheerleader cheerleaders hey go
get him you're gonna be great I believe
in you that doesn't lead into results
you can also identify what things you
need to improve it so how does this
transition into you copywriting and
maybe you got to be thinking bigger with
you know your partners that show how
does that transition into that so my
wife and I had tried to start our first
business what we did start a first
business and it made money but it made
very little money it was a photography
business and
and that gave me that entrepreneurial
Drive like I wanted to do it I had a
little tinge of it when I was selling
for prepaid legal and then really felt
it when I was doing the photography but
I just looked at the dollars and I'm
like this never goes anywhere I can
never make enough money I didn't have
the words to explain it but it was
because I was time for money and you
can't break the wealth equation if
you're dealing in time for money so I
was like all right I want something more
but I don't know what that more is and
then two of my two of the people that
came through and saw me speaking about
filmmaking
were these two entrepreneurs and they
were the two things I had always
promised myself as a kid that I would
have is that one day would have six-pack
abs and one day I would be rich those
are my two promises and that really
guided my life and like a very sincere
and intense way for a long time and they
come across my path not only are they
wildly successful in business but
they're yoked and I was like whoa so
these guys are like yo we're gonna work
together someday and people would tell
me that all the time and I was like yeah
yeah and not really believed it and they
called and said look we're starting this
new company and why don't you come be a
copywriter we settle for employees but
we're always looking for partners and
you can have any role in this company
that you want you just have to become
the right person for that role and I'm
really their pitch yeah and I saw him
make that pitch to everyone dozens of
people whoa dozens and nobody did
anything with it and I was like what the
[ __ ] do people not see like what they're
offering and everyone was telling me
they're full of [ __ ] dude like can you
not see like these guys are just trying
to take advantage of you and I thought
even if they are like what do I have to
lose exactly like as long as my payroll
checks or clearing and they're not doing
the only thing unethical I don't quite
understand the risk so everyone was like
freaking out telling me that I shouldn't
do it and I was just like wow this seems
too like it's too self-evident to me
that I could always go back to teaching
and that I might as well try this and if
it sucks and I'll go back so I did it
tried it they were amazing and true to
their word they were like you can become
anything you want now here's the bad
news you're not yet the person you need
to be and they were just cold-hearted
about it just like real indirect like
you suck at this only an idiot would do
that like they were
so intense what's the age difference
yeah what are they five years older than
me both of them yeah so it was it was
direct it was intense it was not for the
faint of heart or the belly hit from the
jump and for me it was intoxicating and
I fell for it and I was head over heels
like it was so awesome and it was like
my whole life if anybody had been like
that to me I would have shut down
because I didn't believe I could get
better but by the time I meet them I now
believe I can get better so I now I
believe I can get better I'm working out
in the gym so I see this like whoa you
can change your body I've lost all this
weight like it's this crazy
transformation so they come in and
they're like dude the little better you
think you can get is the tip of an
iceberg you can radically transform your
life and this is the playground to do it
and you can get rich and they said look
you're coming to the world with your
hand out right now and if you want to
control the art you have to control the
resources so I was like this is amazing
and so I hear make that pitch all day
every day to a bunch of people nobody
does anything with it I start as the kid
in the server room nobody knew who I was
everyone else in our office had
floor-to-ceiling glass windows that
looked at the Pacific Ocean I was the
only one that didn't I was in a room
with no real desk I just sat at one of
the servers and no one knew they didn't
even introduce me around so people were
just like who's the kid and I was just
like I suck right now so I have to get
better I've got to keep my head down and
work my ass off and get good and I took
that so seriously like when I moved to
cuz at first I lived quite far from them
and so I decided I was gonna move closer
and I timed the locations so I told my
wife she could pick anywhere that I
could get to their place in seven
minutes or less and so we would go look
at an apartment and then I would time it
to their houses and see if I could get
there fast enough and as long as there's
no headquarters I mean is this at the
time at the time that was less relevant
to me than being able to if they needed
me at 2:00 a.m. could I show up you know
in a moment's notice already a 10
percent or you're not temp now Jesus
that lawyer just employee got it this is
how I get to 10 percent God and that's
why I like I when people say like I
don't want to intern or
I want to make sure I'm getting paid
when I'm worth all that stuff it's like
if you're focused in the beginning of
your career with monetizing your current
skill set you will never get where you
want to go because money only spends
once unless you're really good at
investing which most young people are
not whereas skills monetize again and
again again and a great poet so powerful
yeah money only monetizes once or you
can only spend it once but your skills
can be monetized over and over and over
so I just saw it wait a second what I
need is skills these guys have skills
I'm watching them do this they're giving
me a seat at the table such as what can
you kind of loan calls why why the [ __ ]
let me on these phone calls it was like
it doesn't make sense I zero to
contribute and I remember at the
beginning the Oh Patrick the only words
and I don't know if people think I'm
exaggerating when I say this the only
words that I would say on this
conference call would be good bye I
would wait the entire call here it comes
I'm finally gonna get my chance to speak
and I'm not even sure why it meant
something to me but to actually be able
to utter syllables on unlike this
official business call was so important
to me and so I'd wait and I'm like oh
we're wrapping up I can tell it's
happening here it goes goodbye that was
it but I took notes I paid attention I
watched how they were I listened to how
they did business I watch how they
negotiated what they push on what they
didn't what the ethos was all of it and
I just drank it in and then I thought
okay wait a second I can be the energy
of this stuff I may not be able to think
of the ideas yet I don't understand
business but I can be the energy so if
somebody says hey by Thursday we need to
have this I've got that written down hey
guys on Tuesday remember we've got to
have that thing on Thursday does anybody
need help anybody need anything cuz I
will do whatever you want me to do and
so people would give me stuff and I
would do it and as long it was just like
blunt-force trama
and I didn't have to like have some
high-level business knowledge I could
get it done and I would do it with bells
on they once gave me a list like seven
hundred and fifty thousand keywords and
I had to comb through it in an Excel
spreadsheet and say either yes or no
that took days and days and days of
mind-numbing yes no yes no yes no yes no
what do you mean 750 because this was
back in like so we had
words that did we want to advertise on
do we want to advertise on these
keywords like so you would buy a list of
like powerful keywords on Google and
this is all CPC stuff so do we want to
show up on these keywords yes or no like
here's our business you know we're doing
what keywords would we want to show up
on and so I'd have to go and clean the
list there's no way no AI to comb
through it for us so I would do that so
anything like that where I could I just
add value add value add value and
everyone starts gravitating towards the
person who's always upbeat great and
honorable and never says no and is
always asking how they can help it is a
formula that will win for all time and
so that was it and I just threw that
that intensity at it cuz every day I was
like I'm here to get rich I'm here to
get rich and when I get rich I'm gonna
go build my studio I'm gonna get rich
rich rich rich rich and that was all I
thought about obsessed over it now that
would end up being my almost downfall
but that was my obsession and so what
happens they accepted it
so for 8 and 1/2 years I'm doing that I
am working seven days a week
ignoring my wife at about the six and a
half year mark my wife pulls me aside
and says you're now damaging our
marriage and I'm not willing to continue
like this so I was like all right
something's got to give and that forced
me to really look and say I'm profoundly
unhappy and showing up every day chasing
money just isn't actually Who I am and I
need to do something that makes me feel
alive in the moment so it ends up being
a cool part of my story but what I want
people to know is when the following
thing happened I was a wash in shame and
so there I was the guy going hard by
this point I've worked my way up now I'm
the chief marketing officer of the
company I own 10% of it all just through
sweat equity they made good on their
promise and I was so broken inside and
so unhappy that I was like I have to
leave I need to go back to filmmaking I
need to do something that in an in an of
itself like I will love and be
passionate about and what I realized was
the struggle is guaranteed the success
is not now at that time I was a
multi-millionaire on paper but as you
all know being rich on paper is very
different than having money in your
banking audubon so I was rich on paper I
did not feel
rich and so I was like what am i doing
all of this for so my wife and I talked
and I'm like look I know I promised I
would make you rich and I swear to God I
will one day but I'm gonna have to take
a step backwards first because I can't
just muscle through like this I'm just
losing so many years of my life I need
to do something that if I'm gonna fail
at least I'm gonna fail loving what I'm
doing
she was totally behind me she said what
are now famous words in our marriage she
said I bet on you I was like that means
a lot so I go in and I quit and I said
look here's your equity back I'm not
gonna cross the finish line so I don't
think I should get anything for this so
you know take it and and do your thing
and I'm gonna go to Greece we were gonna
move to Greece and I'm gonna write and
that's that and they said look we could
do this without you but we don't want to
and so what would it take for us to keep
working together and I laid out a plan
of if whatever I'm gonna be doing next
it's got to be around value creation
it's got to be around passion it's got
to be something that we would love every
day even if we were failing I want to
build community I want to be myself and
I said look this thing that we now call
social media wasn't called that back
then but social media I think is gonna
change everything what you're is then
this is 20 2009 okay so I'm like I think
this is gonna change everything gonna
change the way that people do business
and actually this probably was a little
bit earlier than that
so the next company I want to be
transparent I want our real personality
personalities to shine through I want
people to see like we actually want good
things for them and so that for three
very different reasons became the core
of what we wanted to do and so we
founded quest nutrition everyone told us
we were crazy that we were leaving
technology like the place where people
actually get rich and going into food
the place where you're in manufacturing
is gonna be small margins you guys are
never gonna survive this and so everyone
thought we were done but our thing was
we're never gonna make decisions based
on profitability again we're gonna be
making it based on like actually adding
value to people's lives being passionate
about what we do every day and loving
our lives and so we actually made a
promise to each of us and we said you're
going to enjoy what you do on a
day-to-day basis simple as and so if
it's something weird like when I started
doing in sidequest fine like even if
it's not like we don't see the immediate
yet ROI in the business if you love it
and that's a part of what's making you a
complete and full human being then let's
do it and so we got into really crazy
stuff ended up being amazing because we
made that promise to each other so that
was how all of that began and then we
just really lived up to it about value
creation about not just trying to sell
people on something about building a
real community to uplift people and it
just so happened that we had the right
product at the right time marketed in a
totally new way because of my background
in film we were creating all of our own
content in-house we built an entire
studio inside the company we were
shooting everything long before that was
like a thing it was like we were doing
that and everyone was like this is crazy
but then we grow by 57,000 percent some
first three years alone that's in
manufacturing that's enough let me tell
you that is absolutely nuts what you
guys did in you know blue ocean strategy
so a lot of time when you look at
Lewisham strategy say wait a minute
who doesn't have a bar everybody's got a
bar you know this part that bar and you
know all of them when you chew on them
they either taste terrible a high
protein or they stick to your tea know
which ones I'm talking about like do you
got like really have jaw muscles to
separate them and then you guys come out
and you do what you do with it
you know but but the questions I want to
I want to ask you is all this is taking
place inside quest
when did you start creating content with
inside course what year was that
[Music]
inside Quest is a lot later in the
journey so that was probably 2014 okay
15 so that when did you go impact Theory
so impact Theory came in 2016 so we did
a year and a half of inside quest and
then I spun it out as a standalone
company for impact theory in 2016
also you there is not two YouTube
channels inside course and now inside
quest became correct impact like we
changed it from Patrick Wade ever to
evaluate Emmy you went from inside
course to I got it and then you said hey
I'm gonna run this and you guys go out
there and do what you're doing and then
you stepped away so the questions I got
did that I really wanted to get into as
personality-wise
you know as I as I listen to a lot of
the stuff you say you know as a kid my
son my son says I said what he wanted be
when you grow up I want to be Peter
Parker okay awesome
you know what do you want to be when you
grow up I want to be this I want to be
that you cannot help yourself but talk
about matrix right and you can't help
your support Auk about Star Wars and and
when you and I spoke at your house
you're like yeah I'm well you know we're
competing against we're gonna build a
media company go against Walt Disney and
all this other stuff and you know we
were already creating comic books and
stories and we're gonna do it oh your
mind is already gone there and then when
I look at your partner Ron Pena he says
William when you asked him what was
especially when in March of 1984 oh I
won and went into martial arts why
because I wanted to be a ninja but then
also he wanted to be Batman like he's
got this one picture doing the splits he
looks like Batman and junk laughs and
them combined and then you got your
partner Mike Osborn who is the Iowa you
know the whole farm boy all that stuff
that he has did you guys all kind of get
along where secret these like listen man
I want to be Batman I want to be this
and I want to be that like did it almost
became okay to talk this crazy language
that to the world is like you guys are
corny and crazy or all of it like it was
that level of connection because that
that's almost what it seems like when I
watch you guys yeah I won't throw a mic
under the bus he that was definitely not
his MO he was not into that stuff but
yeah one of the first things Ron and I
bonded over was comics and our love of
Batman so my dog was actually named
Batman when
Metron serious yeah and I had been
collecting comics since I was 16 so and
the part of the reason that people
gravitate towards Batman is because he
doesn't have superpowers right so and
the the fascinating thing about the
comic industry is if you were actually
in it it grew with the readers so they
became very adult-like if you read
Batman now unless you're reading like
one of the ones aimed at kids it's dark
[ __ ] man like they're really dealing
with like loss and obsession and growth
and like how much you're capable of and
how much you have to hold yourself
accountable it like Batman is is for
growth mindset of people is the story
I'm sorry yeah really you still reward
like how often I try to read my fantasy
would be to read every day I try to read
every week that's great but like even
now in my bag I was reading on the plane
I'm reading a story called I am a hero
but it's very adult zombie apocalypse
but whatever I'm a baseball card again
now do you have any overage like
Superman one you can't afford any of
these but like what do you have what
especially have some Xavier stuff from
the 90s so the problem was that in the
90s so much of it was made there was
this huge speculation boom so it's like
you may have something that's like a big
cultural moment but it's one of a
million that's right
whereas now like there really is rare
stuff where there may have only been
2500 printed period you have no desire
to own that kind of stuff there's a like
thing it isn't isn't the juice it's the
yeah I really believe that the way that
humans assimilate truly disruptive
information is true narrative and so
part of the way that I've changed my
life that I've opened my mind to things
like a growth mindset is through like
the matrix it's not a mistake that the
matrix came out the year that I was
going through this like am I able to
improve myself or not the movie comes
out ends up becoming the dominant
metaphor of my life I'd love to say that
it was a lightning rod moment when I saw
it my life has changed forever it wasn't
like that but it planted a seed that I
just kept coming back to oh man it's
like neo in the matrix ah man like yeah
like like Morpheus said you take the
blue pill
the story ends you wake up in your bed
and believe whatever you want to believe
you take the red pill you stay in
Wonderland and I show you how deep the
rabbit-hole goes
or like Yoda in Star Wars and you just
start piecing together like these
fascinating belief systems because a lot
of times the wisest characters and films
are often taken from like Yoda sounds
exactly like Lao Tzu from the daodejing
yeah so it's like basically you've got
George Lucas who's very familiar with
Eastern philosophy talking Eastern
philosophy through this little puppet
but especially if you hear it when
you're young man like your mind isn't
really open to it so because of Star
Wars I end up becoming obsessed with the
daodejing and then because of that that
ultimately was my doorway to a growth
mindset and then neo and all of that so
the connection was there with you and
Ron was with this area come oh yeah
growth mindset for sure and then comics
and Batman and an obsession over that
rapid style storytelling where you can
explore ideas very very quickly I mean
he says he wanted to be Batman look
would he still say that I don't know if
he'd still say it but he was sincere
like obviously that the ethos of Batman
so not necessarily as a Caped Crusader
Batman by the way to ask sits like this
very you know he's got the jaw he talks
like a very proper guy but in your teens
what movie impact did he like the most
give me each decade what would have been
well Star Wars would have been when I
was young would have been the main
driver then the next one that really had
a big influence on me as as a person
would have been the matrix so I went
from okay Star Wars is like my big thing
then the matrix and now it's like the
matrix is still probably the biggest but
you know there been a lot of films that
have shown me something like ordinary
people I don't know if you've ever seen
that but like seeing how people trapped
themselves in a poor mindset like that
movie to me was so heartbreaking because
the mom just cannot get out of her own
way so they've been a lot of movies that
have like giving me some little peace
but even like a movie that Kramer vs
Kramer or Goonies grotty kid oh my god I
should have led with that Karate Kid was
wildly influential in terms of again
getting picked on not liking the way
people are treating you meeting somebody
who can mentor you that gives you some
yeah you know wise advice but then you
actually have to do it and then
I actually had a wax on wax off moment
in my life this is crazy
so for those that haven't seen the movie
mr. Miyagi's training Daniel and
Daniel's doing what ends up feeling -
Daniel like housework
you know waxing cars painting fences and
he's like why am i doing all this and
mr. Miyagi finally reveals to him that
what he's been training are the motions
for some amazing defenses and in my own
life my dad always made me work and so
through the summers I would always have
summer jobs from the time I was 12 and I
worked in a door factory paint factory
paint store a paint warehouse I mean
just like the worst jobs you can imagine
for a young teenager and my dad always
said like this is gonna pay off one day
and I thought yeah yeah here we go and
so imagine we request and we've ordered
all this equipment and the equipment
shows up in a big tractor-trailer and
they back up we open the door and
there's this massive equipment and we
realize how the hell are we supposed to
get this off the truck
we don't have a forklift and even if we
did no one has knows how to drive it and
I was like actually guys our neighbor
has a forklift and I'm a certified
forklift driver and everyone turns I
mean they're like what why are you a
certified forklift driver but I was like
my dad always made me work in these
stupid places and he told me that one
day would pay off so on camera Ron
starts filming and I turned the camera
as I'm on the forklift and I'm raising
it up and I'm like dad wax on wax off
this phone crazy store so but the the
fascinating thing to me is that the
movie gave me the language and the
framework to understand it to assimilate
that motion or that moment and now be
able to give it to somebody else but you
need that package like you need the
narrative you need that moment something
that hit you on an emotional level for
you to make sense of it so that's a
problem I could have had that same
experience and not put two and two
together it doesn't become part of my
ideology I'm not able to tell somebody
else I'm not even necessarily able to
use it again in my own life because I
have to relearn it every time but a film
a story it gives you that construct so
you can hold the
in your head that's amazing that story
you get there by the way your partner's
three of you guys together obviously
having a business partners difficult by
itself but you're talking three of you
so what ibn Battal were you guys all
evenly split well I read a few plays you
guys were 3333 was anybody 34 did you
guys give one how'd you guys do the
split was it literally split split looks
everybody okay
you were CMO will you see em oh uh I was
president but I oversaw marketing and
sales okay so who was CEO would you say
mike is CEO Mike was CEO like we we kind
of played with the titles because Mike
for sure as an Operations guy and I'm
for sure not I'm the people person but
we just wanted to make sure that
everybody had a title that made sense
for equal partnership so almost look
like you guys didn't want to give any
titles is that a fair assessment
we didn't for that in years okay so you
guys have beef okay you have issue for
instance you gonna have stuff that
happens right was there ever so from
observer everybody is in shape
everybody's discipline so did you guys
have a conversation about pulling your
weight we never had to okay that's
that's that's yeah like that that was
one thing that you we would never need
the conversation you're not pulling your
weight but we would definitely have
conversations you're wrong you're going
in the wrong direction yeah whatever but
ya know with those two guys and and I'll
definitely throw myself in the mix like
not working art I did it every get super
super heated to the point where this is
not gonna work out it was definitely one
time where it got so heated I was like
we actually about to throw punches but
that was rare enough that we could still
be functional but it was look it was
high intensity you definitely have guys
that aren't there to play around but at
the end of the day there was so much
respect yeah so much respect and a real
desire to win and when you've got
winners on your team the last thing you
want to do is let like any sort of
pettiness get in the way so we would
actually have conversations about our
emotions like hey when you did that it
made me feel this way really yeah yeah
yeah all of you yeah yeah did you guys
have a code together like did you guys
have something like a code of honor not
stated or anything like that but yeah it
was like look we're gonna be diehard
we're going to do anything
within our code of ethics to make this
company successful we're gonna also
support each other we're gonna look for
ways to help each other shine we're not
gonna like backstab like we were so
cognizant that internecine battles are
ultimately the thing that bring you down
we were very cognizant the pairing up is
a problem so if two of us are really
close because I mean we were together
for 14 years so over that time it's like
inevitably up one time you're feeling
close to one person the other you're
feeling closer to the other person so
it's like you you have to talk openly
and say things like hey remember
coupling is one of the most dangerous
things that we could face in a triumph
erence we have to be very careful not to
let that happen
making sure that we're talking about
emotions that if something upset you
that you put it out on the table that
you talk about it and that we make sure
that we're very open and honest and
direct and I'll say that it became hard
for other people because we were so
direct with each other and so
comfortable in that directness that if
you then were direct like that with
somebody else in a way that you loved
because it was so clear people felt like
you were being like cold or whatever
like just to give you an idea if we
wanted one of the other people to come
to us efficiency was one of our highest
values so you would just get a text it
would say come and it wasn't hey can you
please come to the office whatever it
was you would just get a text come and
so whoever sent it that meant go to
their office but you would send the same
text like you didn't think about it but
we had that kind of just ultra direct
everything is efficient now you have
known each other since 1989 you you came
in the picture earlier because they want
to create a new position lay right I
know I'm sorry you came in a picture
late my apologies yeah I meant to say
late so if you had to do it again or I
guess this is the question um because a
lot of people ask and say partnership
partnership partnership do you see a
benefit more in three than two because
no matter when there's a to one unites
or do you see benefit in two over three
or solo who I don't I don't think
there's any way to answer that question
in the generic so let me walk through
the advantages and disadvantages of each
so as a solopreneur you will have the
most fun but I think your likelihood of
going out of business is the highest
because you don't have anybody checking
you so because it is very hard I know
because I try every single day it is
very hard to get your employees to
challenge you especially openly so that
means you're not
all the good ideas and there's no
universe in which you have all the good
ideas I don't care how smart you are so
when there's no one who's your equal it
gets really hard to make sure that you
have total clarity and that when you're
acting in a way that does not behoove
the company that somebody feels
completely comfortable saying that's not
working and when you don't have that
that's dangerous but like having a
vision and just being able to execute
and not have to convince people is fun
so and if you're right then hey it's
great I think that's probably also where
the it's lonely at the top phrase comes
from now because I've never been alone
at the top for me like that
there's no ring of truth to that so I've
always had partners now when I had three
partners it was really complicated and
trying to make sure that you're both
doing what's right for the company and
doing something that makes everybody
feel good and then if you have different
like parents that are of different
religions on those areas we have a
collision of values that's problematic
because your likelihood of convincing
somebody to change their mind is good
your likelihood of convincing to change
someone's values is virtually zero like
it is so deeply ingrained in who they
are they mistake it for the truth of the
world right so it's like if I don't mean
it in a religious context but when you
start thinking about religious values
you get how entrenched people become so
take two parents that have different
religions and they want to raise their
kid so then mistakes are high the stakes
may be this child will go to hell if
they're not raised in the way that I
want you have two people thinking the
same thing so you could definitely run
into that in business where you get that
like if we do what you're saying we're
gonna lose the business and they're
thinking if we do what you say we're
gonna lose the business right now you
have a collision of values that's hard
and so navigating your way through that
is very very difficult but when you have
three people that hold each other in
very high esteem that have an insane
degree of trust that have been in the
trenches for a long time you've seen
them at their most vulnerable and they
still show up but you show up for you
like when you have that kind of history
then it's really extraordinary but if
you don't have that history so finding a
partner that you're gonna make an equal
partner right from the jump is is tough
now a partnership of two you can get
into a deadlock and so at least when
there's three there's a third person to
be like yellow
with this person on this and so there's
always somebody to break the tie it's
there's never like well how about this
we were never in a situation where we
were in a three-way deadlock so it was
just far too easy one person knew wow
this one's either close enough to what I
want anyway or whatever I'm just gonna
go with that and vote so somebody was
always getting out voted ganas knew from
time to time you're gonna get outvoted
and this may be the key as long as
everybody actually wants their other two
partners to win it works so if I always
want my way to be right and I don't give
a [ __ ] about you or your feelings then
it's gonna be bad you and I are gonna
have animosity but if I actually want
you to win it and so I'm like I think
I'm right this time but I know what it's
like to always have someone else's idea
win and I never get to see if my idea
work so even though I think I'm right
I'm gonna disagree but I'm gonna commit
to your idea and that hold disagree but
commit was a big thing this is me but
commit I disagree but commit like if
when we walk out this door no one will
be able to tell which one of us
disagreed because we will be so diehard
about all of them so that was a real
thing I love that so now my partnership
is with my wife and when we created the
company impact the impact just the two
of you listen to no one else
nothing any plans are bringing anybody
in all of our employees have basically
phantom shares so they have ownership if
we sold they'd get a few but they don't
vote or anything like that okay so no I
would be shocked if we did that well
Never Say Never but I'd be surprised and
when we created it I told the lawyer
create the ultimate divorce nightmare
and my wife is like whoa
you take 51 I'll take 49 like there's no
need to do that the lawyers were like
listen to her
you take 51 she takes 49 it just makes
things clear Tom and I said no
fifty-fifty because a my marriage is my
highest priority the business comes a
distant second and - if I say to her
were equals in every way but I don't
trust you quite enough to give you equal
percentage even though she agrees it
sends a signal to her that there's I'm
hedging my bets and the reality is I
know that does the people
psychologically so and that's the exact
reason at Qwest that we were 33 and 1/3
each just there's you don't get any
benefit by making it different and you
get
massive dissent when it's off so when
you guys have an account flick then
you're trying to make a decision was it
Tom's the final this is you make grouse
two out of three yeah so majority yeah
all very simple so they're easy so hey
200 let's go with it I disagree but we
got two out of three and it was it was a
lot more interpersonal than that that
was sort of the truth of it but we
really did like there was such a deep
Brotherhood yeah that that was a real
presence in all of this it was like
you're really talking through it you're
being sensitive to how the other person
feels so you're being strategic there's
no question like you have to think of
the business but we were always trying
to walk that line of like I don't want
to hurt you I don't want to like piss
you off like it's not about that I'll
push you if I have to no question and if
you get upset even though that's not my
intent that's gonna happen from time to
time we all have to be big boys and deal
with it and also you have to learn to
let go and recenter yourself and not be
emotional and so we weren't spiteful so
it's like it's really [ __ ]
complicated and that's why it wouldn't
work for everyone but we did it for a
very long time that's very impressive I
got to tell you four to twelve three
obviously to me it seems like Mike's the
easiest personality that's what it
seemed like you know simple guy came up
you didn't see a lot of stuff he seems
like a very simple guy well going back
to the whole question about partnership
are you still fully involved or not at
all like you are not no board
responsibilities like any sort of
responsibility
I have massive ownership day-to-day
responsibility zero I just like when I
exited the first time and I said hey
here's your equity back this time I said
look I can't expect to know what's right
for the company if I'm off running this
other company so I'm going to
acknowledge that it doesn't make sense
for me to hold a board seat so I'm gonna
give up the boards knowing when I left I
thought it is entirely possible that I
never see another dime from this company
cuz they could run it into the ground
without me that's entirely possible
so my still have a lot of paper wealth
yeah oh yeah yeah you're okay with not
having any I've made so much real bank
account wealth that if I never make
another dollar I'll still never have to
work again so could you that to me like
at some point you're so rich the only
thing that matters is time and all of
this
the whole journey was I wanted to be a
filmmaker and I only got in business to
get rich so I could go make movies so it
didn't make sense to me
I and I stayed for like two years after
we had a liquidation event and I was
like I never have to work again I never
have to do anything I don't want I could
start making movies today Multi
eight-figure check tap of a deal yes
okay good so are you a from the mindset
of Enzo and Walt Disney where they say
you know we don't make movies to make
money oh we don't make cars to make
money we make money to race cars and we
make money to make is that kind of your
mindset as well sort of if you'll swap
that out for I'm making I'm telling
stories is the truest way to say it as a
way to pull people out of the matrix by
giving them an empowering mindset
because I really believe the only way to
reach the masses is on an emotional
level I'm not good at music
so that leaves film and television
essentially that's great
so what you and I were speaking I asked
a question by kids and we had an
interesting conversation by kids and I
have a lot of respect on how you guys
came with your decision and by the way I
actually recommend the way you made your
decision to some people because I think
some people make the decision based on
what everybody else is doing
you guys didn't you know so you told me
that at one point you and your wife said
we don't want to have kids and we're
totally okay with that
how did you process that together so
when we met we both just assumed we were
gonna have kids and that seemed pretty
obvious to me I really enjoy that kind
of relationship being a mentor is
something that's you know pretty
powerful and to do with your own child
seems really extraordinary I was a big
brother for eight and a half years for
one kid so when I say that I got to know
him so much so that he was unfortunately
being abused at home and so he was
removed from his home and I was made the
Guardian to help him into the court
system like that's how close we were and
so I get it man I get how beautiful and
powerful that kind of relationship is
but the reality is being a parent to me
is about fulfillment it's about doing
something so beautiful that it gives you
something that you could not have gotten
any other way which I'll shorthand if a
film
and I think it is an extraordinary path
to fulfillment for a large swath of the
population but it also changes the
course of your life without question and
I was asking people all the time when I
really was like we're sort of getting
into the do-or-die years I would ask
everyone I could should I have kids or
not having kids and I just want to get
their wisdom and this one guy gave me
advice he said Tom have kids don't have
kids it doesn't matter but whatever you
do do it all the way and I said to him
that's the best piece of advice I'm ever
gonna get I'm gonna remember that for a
very long time because the truth of it
doesn't really matter it's just a life
choice among many life choices that you
can make and it will be beautiful and
wonderful and if you do it you'll love
it but you'll hate it if you do it but
then wish that you were over here you
know doing the entrepreneur thing a
hundred and ten hours a week and you
know but when you're there you're
wishing you were at home with your
family which is where you find a lot of
really hardcore entrepreneurs and so I
was like ok that's not the the Schism
that I want I just want to focus on this
thing and then it just became really
easy once Lisa became an entrepreneur
and she found fulfillment in that then
we were both completely fulfilled by
what we were trying to build so then it
was like okay we that desire to have a
child just basically went away purely
logical yeah now what if Lisa says five
years from now listen you have changed
my mind
where would you be unless I change my
mind as well the talk would go like it
went at the beginning if that's what I
said to her cuz I came to that
conclusion it's a very seriously over
session a lot a couple seven I know you
guys got a couples show that you do as
well so you know this kind of stuff
comes up yeah so I'll give people the
magic words
so here's what I said to her when she
wanted kids still and I now knew that I
did not and I said I would never deny
that for you like if that's what you
want then that's what we're gonna do but
I want to be really clear about what the
division of labor is going to be so I'm
gonna be a good father and I'm going to
put the time in that I need you to be a
good father
but I am NOT going to be taking them to
school functions I'm not gonna be
changing diapers I'm not getting up in
the middle of the night I'll have a
nanny do it for you it's not like I'm
expecting you to do it I'm just letting
you know I won't be doing it so if
you're completely comfortable with that
that I
we'll be finding ways to build
efficiencies so that only time spent
that is quality time bonding time with a
child that is the only time we'll be
spending with them and all of the hard
[ __ ] know that it's gonna fall on
your shoulders outsource as much as you
want but everything else that you want
to take on don't get bitter with me
because I'm not doing it
so if you're comfortable with that and
we'll lay everything out and like super
detail and I said I'm even happy to
draft a contract so that we're not
unclear about what roles are then yes
because I could never deny you being a
mother if that's what you want so if she
came to me in five years and said that
that would be the speech concerns future
wise you see a lot of people right now
talking about well the biggest concern
right now for the future is this the
biggest concern right now for the future
is this is there anything not as an
individual you're not a guy that I
foresee myself saying I'm concerned
about anything like you say you say Pat
the way I live is I live in a moment you
know I literally can die in 15 minutes
media can hit me no literally I believe
that that's your mindset that you have
but the average person like is there
anything that you would say here are the
two or three things or one thing that is
going to probably impact everybody's
life in the next 5 10 20 years yeah
there's there's two things one is AI and
robotics are going to disrupt the
economy that that is just a for sure and
I'll peg that I often say 5 to 7 years
it'll happen within 10 years to be sure
at a minimum it's going to displace 20
million drivers so I think everyone can
get their head around that but if you've
seen some of the agricultural robots
that pick weeds and use less fertilizer
and all that like their there are just
things coming that people can't possibly
predict and that's really gonna happen
it's certainly not an accident that
that's the theme of the comic book neon
future that I'm writing so that I think
is big and I think that people really
have to prepare themselves for it and
the way that you prepare yourself for it
is the next problem which is generations
move in cycles and no generation is
better or worse than the other I just
think that the personalities of a
generation either suit them too or make
them ill suited to what is happening to
their generation so the generation right
now is rebelling against
the capitalistic die hard go get yours
work your ass off work 110 hours and
mass as many resources as you can so
they think that's gross so they're
pushing back on that hard now the
problem with the push back is the way
they see it is we should be taken care
of there are just certain basic in a
Leah Beale inalienable human rights that
we should have things like universal
basic income that we should have
guaranteed outcomes stuff like that okay
I get it emotion I get why they want
that to be true the problem is the
physics of the world and the physics of
culture don't give a [ __ ] what you think
or want there's just going to be a
reality and you're either suited for
that reality or ill-suited so we're
about to hit an inflection point in the
generation where with all of their
amazing intentions and all the beautiful
things that they're trying to bring to
the world they're gonna realize that
they're trying to put the onus to
protect and serve on to exterior things
rather than saying I have an obligation
me and the example that I always tell
people is if a meteorite were to strike
my wife and kill her I wouldn't blame
anybody but me that is entirely my fault
and I can back that up because people
like Tom is so ridiculous how could a
meteorite striking your wife and killing
or be your fault that's dumb luck divine
providence like fate whatever you want
to call it but Jesus man it's ridiculous
to blame yourself and then I point out
I'm on the board of the XPrize at the
XPrize there was a prize presented that
would allow us to track near-earth
objects better than we are today
I voted it down there because I don't
think it matters I don't think that the
likelihood is high enough but it's there
I know that there's an organization
right now that already tracks near-earth
objects I've never sent them a dime of
my money I've never called them to
encourage them I've never sent them an
email with ideas nothing now I know all
of this stuff exists and I do nothing to
stop it from happening so the only thing
that I can say if my wife were killed by
a meteorite is I did nothing to stop it
I could have made a different decision
and got a different outcome I need to
focus on that to remind myself I can
always make a change I can always do
something different and get a different
outcome
so if you come in and you disrupt my
industry my first thought is not the
world
what are you doing this is so terrible
and sinister we have to stop AI or
whatever my first reaction is how do I
become more adaptive and
people are putting so much energy into
thinking like I'm frail and weak I have
to be protected that they become frail
and weak when in reality they are not my
favorite quote on the planet is Darwin
is often misquoted as saying is the
strongest of the species that survived
he did not say that what he actually
said was it's not the strongest of the
species that survives nor the most
intelligent but rather the most adaptive
to change that's how humans became the
apex predator we are the most adaptive
species on the planet you can take us
anywhere and we will thrive and it is
that ability to adapt mentally and
physically that makes us amazing but you
have to believe you can get better
so it's this freakish irony of you have
all this latent potential but if you
don't believe it's there you can't
manifest it and so the very first thing
is people have got to reject this notion
that they have to be protected from the
outside and putting all their time and
energy into that be the [ __ ] change
you want to see in the world if you want
to see people strong enough to withhold
a better wait then don't worry about
trying to fix systems just [ __ ] get
tough watch how people respond to you
watch all your kids look up to you watch
how your family members look up to you
watch how people turn to you and want
help people we have an innate desire to
get strong we don't have an innate
desire to have something else protect us
all of us if two buttons man one of them
is you're such a badass nothing can ever
hurt you you can get it you know how to
figure it out you fight your way out of
anything or a magic fairy will follow
behind you and just walk things away the
terrifying thing is this button the
magic fairy is going to get pressed a
[ __ ] of a lot more than this button but
this button no one dies of suicide with
this button this button [ __ ] race
towards suicide and depression and if
you want to know why we're having a
pandemic of that and I don't want to
cheapen it cuz it's largely microbiome
and there's all kinds of health things
that are going on I'm not taking that
away but on the mental side of what's
driving a lot of people not believing in
that is we're just culturally
reinforcing that like we're stuck we're
trapped there's nothing we can do that
people don't understand the fulfillment
has to be earned you can't tell someone
to just love themselves you have to tell
them how they earn self-respect you have
to tell them that doing hard [ __ ] that
you don't want to do and doing it anyway
that's exactly how you gain self-worth
you can't
tell someone to feel worthy and [ __ ] man
I want two more than the next person
like I I spend an inordinate amount of
my time every week talking to a camera
trying to help people to touch their
lives for real like my wife and I made
so much money we could have actually
bought an island and retired and never
worked again but that's not what I want
like I want that fulfillment I want to
do hard [ __ ] I want to touch people's
lives I want to lift them up actually
want to transform and change them and so
I believe in people and I'm Way
compassionate this is not me saying like
Oh kids today get off my lawn this is
like I get it this is the nature of
cyclical cycle yeah like in in culture
this happens you rebel against your
parents and since my parents were coming
out of the the war and they believed
that like the world could be better and
the world was better for them like I
caught the tail into that and so I'm so
optimistic about [ __ ] so when I
encountered a growth mindset I was ready
to take it in but now we have like a
generation that's really pushing back on
those notions of just like self
ownership self authorship of recognizing
no one's response no one is responsible
for the difficulties in your life but
you that's powerful very powerful so so
to stay on this so you're not a fan of
the universal basic income of $1,000 a
month to any American no matter what and
adding two trillion dollars to of cost
every year you're definitely against it
here's the thing I don't know [ __ ] about
it I know I know the psychology of
humans and if somebody showed me that by
doing that that people in droves would
go develop themselves and they would
stop asking for a lighter load and they
would start working for stronger
shoulders if that really is what
happened and it just like hey Tom you
you free up that layer of panic over
safety and now people really are
empowering themselves I'd like to give
them more but I have not seen the truth
of that in the way that humans are I
find that they get terrified that that
will go away they try to hoard more
resources and it it just goes bananas
it's not even that it's just people lay
around and play xbox I don't think
they're gonna get enough to lay around
and play xbox so it just gets into this
how do I get people to give me more and
man I've seen that play out like giving
a severance package that you know is
crazy generous and then people like are
offended by it you're like what it's
crazy time you know that about a night I
know exactly two questions before we
wrap up one is you're you're big on
learning a lot of skill sets right what
would you say has the highest what skill
set has the highest up set highest
return the the baseline thing people
have to have is emotional resilience so
you have to and this to me is a skill
you have to learn how to emotionally
recalibrate so when I was the kid in the
server room and there was a whole bunch
of people farther ahead in their
entrepreneurial journey than I and they
all heard the same message about you can
be a partner and none of them did
anything with it
I started asking why aren't they doing
anything with it and I realized the
answer was I could self-soothe faster
than they could and so yeah it hurt when
I was told I was an idiot that really
sucked especially hearing it from
someone you really respect but I decided
to not spin out of control not waste
three days being hurt by it but instead
to recenter and just ask are they right
because if they're right there's
something to learn here and if they're
not right just move on and if they are
right learn the lesson and so I just
slowly started collecting it and the
lessons and the image I started thinking
was whenever somebody throws an insult
at you you have two options you can let
it hit you in the head or you can raise
your defenses and defect it and your
defenses are the psychological immune
system they're real I'm not making that
up so all of us have this thing that
comes to our aid when somebody says
something that hurts you then you're
like oh well they're mean anyway they're
a jerk they're a bully whatever I don't
have to take them seriously and so that
makes you feel better and you believe
maybe that they're being cosmically
punished in some way being a bully is
its own punishment and all that so and I
like that allows you to relax and
they've done studies that show people
with the highest level of self delusion
are the happiest so there really is
something to it but the people at the
highest levels self delusion are usually
not the ones that go the farthest
because they don't stop to recognize
where they really are to own the pain of
that so I thought okay instead of
raising my defenses I'm going to lower
my defenses I'm gonna let that
rock hit me in the head because at my
feet now is actually a nugget of gold
and I'm gonna pick up that nugget of
gold and format a lesson that the person
is throwing at me and here's the thing
to realize when people really come at
you they're really trying to hurt you
they have sinister intent they're gonna
come at you with something that's true
nobody comes at you with the stuff
that's not real they're gonna hit you
with like the thing you're the most
secure about in the world so even the
people with the gravest of intent are
the ones that are giving you the most
powerful gift because you may be blind
to it or maybe you didn't want to
acknowledge it but if you can let it hit
you as much as it hurts
then bend down pick it up and learn from
it now you can do something know that
person will become unstoppable very very
true Tom how do you process issues how
do you do you have a system of where you
go through something happen something
comes up in your brain is there step
process you go through yes what is it
starts with the goal so what is my goal
well first it starts with clearing the
emotion because probably whatever I was
told just had some emotion I recenter
myself the thing that I probably repeat
to myself the most is you can do
anything you set your mind to on a long
enough timeline so I know I can learn
anything so if the thing that hits me is
overwhelming because I'm scared I don't
know how to do it you can do anything
you set your mind to so at the end of
this thinking through is going to be the
question are you willing to set your
mind to it or not and then I identify
okay what's my goal does this move me
towards my goal yes or no I think
through the process of has somebody done
it is there already a well-laid path
from where I'm at to actually completing
this which is how I decided that we're
gonna take on Disney because looking at
the only studio ever in the history of
time to be disciplined enough to only
tell one kind of story from a thousand
different angles so much so that they
gave birth to Americana is Disney no
other studio everyone else is all over
the map if I say I'm gonna go see a Sony
movie or a Paramount movie you don't
know anything about it but if I say I'm
gonna go see a Disney movie you already
know something so their name brand means
something so I could see oh there's a
path from where I'm at to the impact
that I want to have so I throw that out
just as a reminder of the path that I'm
walking more than I have some particular
obsession with Disney fascinating and by
the way and you're in your mind do you
see it already that vision becoming a
reality on question no question no
question about it for sure and look I
have days of where I'm like how the
you're gonna do this but then you come
back - you can learn anything you set
your mind to so just keep marching
forward yeah I like what you said was
you said you know the whole thing about
when you get to 75% you know you're
they're like man it's gotta happen why
isn't it kind of happening already you
know that whole thing we're about to
score a touchdown where would you say
you are right now on the on the process
of doing that division it's a 70 year
plan so we are we were on our app salute
infancy but I think that we're you could
put me up against just about anybody
else and on the same amount of time I'd
say we're ahead of anybody else really
for sure that confident yes powerful
well Tom it's been great having you by
the way if you're watching this right
now you heard so many different things
we talked about business partnership
should you have kids should you not have
kids you ought to go out there and
follow this content as what we're gonna
put all the link here below but having
said that brother thank you so much for
coming out I think you're very
interesting sitting on with you yes